in the last video we talked about the
idea that if I start with some type of a
string there and if I were to take the
left end of the string I could just as
equally have done the right but if I
take the left end of the string and jerk
it up then all the way down and then
back to its resting position it'll
generate this disturbance in the string
and the disturbance might initially look
like this after I've done that jerking
up and down once and that disturbance is
going to propagate down the string it's
going to move down the string like that
let me color this in in black so this is
right after I do that first cycle that
first jerking up and down the string
might look something like that and if we
wait a little while the string might
look something like this assuming that
that's I only did that once the string
might look something like this where
that pulse has actually propagated down
the string that pulse has propagated
down the string and we in the last video
we said hey this disturbance that's
propagating down the string or
propagating down this medium although it
doesn't necessarily have to have a
medium we call this we call this a wave
and in particular this wave right here
this is a pulse this is a pulse wave
because we only have essentially one
perturbation of the string now if I kept
doing that if I kept going up and down
and up and down essentially if I
periodically did it at regular intervals
then my string would look something like
this it would look something like this
it would look something doing my best to
draw it neatly it might look something
like this where once again the
perturbations are going to where the
disturbances are going to move to the
right they're going to move to the right
with some velocity and what I want to do
in this video is really focus on this
type of wave this type of wave right
here which you can imagine since I'm
periodically moving this left side up
and down up and down and creating these
periodic movements in the wave we call
this a periodic wave this is a periodic
periodic wave the motion is repeated
over and over again so what I want to
talk about is some of the properties of
a periodic wave
now the first thing you might say is
well hey you know how far are you
jerking it up and down how far are these
movements from rest so if this is kind
of the resting position right there how
far these movements up and above the
resting position and below the resting
position and we call that the amplitude
of the wave so that distance right there
I'll do it in magenta that distance
right there is the amplitude amplitude
amplitude sometimes Mariners will have
an idea of wave height wave height they
normally refer to from the bottom from
the trough of a wave to its peak
amplitude we're talking about from the
resting position to its peak so let me
label peak well I think you know what
peak means peak is the highest point on
the wave that's the peak and that's the
trough if you're in a fishing boat and
you wanted to see how big a wave is
you'd probably care about the wave
height not so much the L you you know if
you're both sitting down here you have
to care about this whole distance but
anyway we won't talk too much about that
so that's kind of the first interesting
idea behind a wave is G and you know not
all waves are being generated by Sal
jiggling a string on the left-hand side
but I think you get the idea that these
waves can represent many different these
this graph can represent many different
types of wave forms and this essentially
displacement from the resting position
or from the zero position that is your
amplitude now the next question you
might ask is okay I know how far you're
jiggling this wrist this string up and
down but how quickly are you doing it so
how long does it take for you to go all
the way up all the way down and back
again so how long for each cycle we
could say you know a cycle is me going
up down back again how long for each
cycle or you might say how long for each
period right we're saying this is
periodic each period is each repetition
of the wave so this idea of how long for
each cycle we call that the period we
call that the period and this is going
to be
a unit of time maybe I'm doing it every
two seconds it takes me two seconds to
go up down back again up down back again
that's going to be two seconds now a
very related term is is how many cycles
am i doing per second how many cycles
cycles per second so notice this is how
long or you could say how many seconds
for each cycle we could even write that
assuming we're dealing with second how
many seconds for each cycle so for
example this you know a period it might
look like something like five seconds
per cycle or maybe it's two seconds per
cycle but then what if we're asked how
many cycles per second so we're asking
the opposite question and not how long
how many seconds does it take for me to
go up down and back again we're saying
in each second how many times am I going
up down back again so how many cycles
per second that's the inverse of period
so period the notation is normally a big
capital T for period this is frequency
this is frequency frequency frequency
it's normally denoted by an F and this
you're going to say cycles per second so
if you're going five seconds per cycle
that means you're doing one fifth of a
cycle per or 1/5 of a 1/5 of a cycle per
second all I did is invert this that
right there and that makes sense because
the period and the frequency are
inversions of each other this is how
many psych seconds per cycle how long
does one up down back again take and
this is how many up down back again are
there in a second so they're inverses of
each other so we could say that
frequency is equal to 1 over the period
or you could say that period is equal to
1 over the frequency so if I told you if
I told you that I'm I'm vibrating the
left end of this
rope at let's say it's ten cycles ten
cycles per second and by the way the
unit of cycles per second this is a
Hertz so that I could have also written
this down as ten Hertz which you've
probably heard before ten Hertz just
mean ten cycles per second if it's if my
frequency is ten cycles per second my
period is going to be one over that so
one over ten it's going to be one over
ten seconds per cycle which makes sense
if I can in ten times I can go up and
down a hole up down back again if I can
do that ten times in a second it's going
to take me one tenth of a second to do
it each time now another question we
might ask ourselves is how quickly is
this wave moving in this case to the
right since I'm jiggling the left end of
the string how quickly is it moving to
the right so the velocity so to do that
we need to figure out well how far did
the wave go after one cycle or after one
period so you know after I jiggle this
once how far did the wave go right what
is this distance from this resting point
to this resting point there and we call
that a wavelength that is a wave length
and there's a lot of different ways you
can define a wave length you could view
a wave length as how far the initial
pulse went after completing exactly one
cycle or you could view it as the
distance from one peak to another peak
that is also going to be the wavelength
or you could view it as a distance from
one trough to the other trough that's
also the wavelength or in general you
can view the the wavelength as one
exactly equal point on the wave so
exactly you know from that distance to
that distance that is also that is also
one wavelength where you're completing
between that point in that point you're
completing one entire cycle to get
exactly back to that same point and when
I say exactly back to that same point
this point doesn't count because this
point although we're in the same
position we're now going down we
go to the point where we're in the same
position and notice over here we're
going up we want to be going up again so
this isn't this distance is not one
wavelength to go one wavelength we have
to go back to the same position and
we're moving in the same direction so
this is also one wavelength so if we
know how far we've traveled after one
period so let me write it this way so
wavelength wavelength is equal to how
far how far the wave has traveled after
one period after one actually or after
one period or you could say after one
cycle or one cycle because remember a
period is how long does it take to
complete one cycle one complete up down
and back again motion so if we know how
far we've traveled and we know how long
it took us it took us one period how can
we figure out the velocity well the
velocity velocity is equal to is equal
to distance divided by time is equal to
distance I'll write it out is equal to
distance divided by time well for a wave
your velocity and I could write it as a
vector but I think you get the general
idea your velocity what's the distance
you travel in a period well the distance
you travel in a period is your
wavelength is your wavelength right
after one after one up down back again
the wave pulse would have traveled
exactly that far that would be my
wavelength so I've traveled a distance
of a wavelength and how long did it take
me to travel that distance well it took
me a period to travel that distance so
it's wavelength divided by period
divided by period now I just said that
one over the period one over the period
is the same thing as the frequency so
this could be I could rewrite this as
wavelength and so actually I should be
clear here the notation for wavelength
tends to be the Greek letter lambda so
we could say velocity velocity is equal
to
wavelength over period which is the same
thing as wavelength times one over my
period and we just said that one over
the period this is the same thing as
your frequency so weight velocity is
equal to wavelength times your frequency
and if you know this you can pretty much
solve all of the basic problems that you
might encounter in waves so for example
if someone tells you that I have a
velocity a velocity of I don't know 100
meters per second to the right so in
that direction velocity you have to give
a direction and they were that they were
to tell you that my frequency my
frequency is equal to I don't know let's
say there my frequency is 20 cycles per
second which is the same thing as 20
Hertz so literally if you were if you
were only to see this if you had a
little window where you're only able to
observe this part of your wave you only
observe that part of my string if we're
talking about 20 Hertz then in one
second you would see this go up and down
20 times 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
everything is then 19 20 that would
happen in 1 that is exactly 1 second you
would see this go up and down 20 times
that's what we mean by the frequency
being 20 Hertz or 20 cycles per second
so they gave you the velocity they gave
you the frequency what's the wave length
here so the wave length in this
situation you would say the velocity let
me write it over here your velocity is
equal to your wave length times your
frequency times your frequency divide
both sides by 20 and actually let me
make sure I get the meter the unit's
right so this is meters per second is
equal to lambda times 20 cycles cycles
per second so if you divide both sides
by 20 cycles per second you get 100
meters per second times 1 over 20
seconds per cycle and then you this
becomes a 5 this becomes a 1 so you get
5 and then the seconds cancel out
and seconds so you get five meters per
cycle so this is equal to five meters
per cycle which would be your wavelength
in this situation so it's five meters
you could say five meters per cycle but
wavelength implies that you're talking
about the distance per cycle so in this
situation if this if this is moving to
the right at 100 meters per second and
this frequency I see this moving up and
down 20 times in a second then this
distance right here must be five meters
likewise we can figure out the period
very easily the period here is just
going to be one over the frequency it's
going to be one over 20 seconds seconds
per cycle so using this you know these
formulas and I don't want you to
memorize the formula I want to be able
to kind of it should be intuitive for
you and hopefully this video made it a
little bit intuitive but using this you
can really answer almost any question if
you're given two or two of these
variables and you need to solve for the
third
anyway hopefully you found that helpful